people often think of field goals as
being harder for being farther away
but that's not the main problem
field goals in the nfl mill can make or
break a game
particularly long distance ones but once
that ball gets snapped and you hold it
what sort of
difference does the angle of the player
holding it make
i can't speak with authority on this but
i would bet different kickers have
different preferred angles but let me
just say your foot it has a round
front to it and the ball is round and
when round things hit round things
a fraction of an inch can make a
difference between something that
careens
off to the left goes too high or is
exactly where you want it to be did what
was his name
dempsey he had a club foot right so he
had a birth defect
and he had a special shoe fitted to his
foot and the front
side of that shoe was completely flat so
he hit a round ball with a flat surface
completely an advantage because that
removes
the the the precisional uncertainty
between a round surface
hitting another round surface let's look
at the planetary rotation does that oh
yeah
so if you have a north south stadium and
many are
if it's oriented that way and the kicker
kicks the ball
depending on how high and how long it's
in the air the
rotation of the earth can have a
significant effect
on its trajectory towards the goal post
if you're trying to make a 50-yard field
goal
that's far away enough and the ball is
airborne long enough
for the rotation of the earth to deflect
it to the right
by a third of an inch cincinnati bengals
against i forgot who was it
uh seattle seahawks in overtime sudden
death kick
and the kick went up and everybody's
heart stops and no one breathes
and there it tumbles and it hit the left
upright and went in for the win but kind
of barely went in
and then i tweeted i said this game was
one assisted by
the rotation of the earth and that force
that makes that happen is the same force
that sends hurricanes rotating
counterclockwise
in the northern hemisphere and clockwise
in the southern here well by the way
talk about wind you know they're playing
games in empty stadiums now people the
fact that you're this thing
sitting there in a chair and you're not
smooth
any wind that would otherwise circulate
unimpeded among the seats has friction
against the fans you would expect wind
speeds and wind gusts
especially gusts to be higher in a
perfectly cleaned out stadium than
in one that has 50 000 screaming fans
the direction the flags are going is not
always the direction the wind is blowing
down on the field so
what you should have in the modern
stadium is anemometers throughout the
state
all right these are the wind speed
detectors that you can say oh it's
at 12 miles an hour over there five
miles an hour over here let me hit the
ball in this direction or kick the ball
that way
i would just love to see neil as a field
goal kicker running out on the field
just going
i'm gonna need a protractor not a
protractor
oh